Hi all, I have had some blood results come back from a finger prick test as my doctor refused
to allow me to have any tests done. So I've done, I've had my results and they have shown
to be slightly low on B12. So I think this person is saying they're doctor refused to order labs
for horses. So she ordered some different blood spot labs, which you could do. Anybody could
order blood spot labs. You do a finger prick blood spot test and you can get different labs done.
You can do it from home without a without a goaded and get a draw. However, how do I know what the
healthy amount should be? So it will be 12. Do I go along with the NHS sites say, say low high
normal or I just don't trust what is given to me by the general practitioners? Good question.
Actually, I have a video of this that talks about lab value normals. So there's in in short,
so I recommend get to our site to watch that video. It's on our blog post if you look at blood tests on
our blog post, probably throughout that. But there are different labs who will have different
normal lab ranges. So there's lab value normal and abnormal lab ranges and then there's what's called
functional lab value ranges. For vitamin B12, I think the I think most lab value ranges is between
35 and probably one 65 or something like that. I know the functional range is like 65 to one 65.
You almost never have to worry about elevated B12 levels. If a person is taking B12,
most of the time they will show elevated B12 levels when you do a blood test. You could just
pretty much ignore that. That can be a sign that B12 isn't getting in the cell, but really what you're
concerned about is low B12. So there's a couple reasons why you'll have low B12. So if it's on the
lab value is down near the low range, you could pretty much assume that it's functionally low.
And a person will have functionally low B12 for a number of different reasons. They can have
intrinsic factor issues genetically. They don't make enough intrinsic factor. Intrinsic factor is made
by the prior cells in the stomach and that's what you need to absorb B12. You can have absorption
issues for other reasons, gut issues, gut inflammation. Hypochloridria is a very common, maybe unique,
most common reason for low B12. If you have a decreased stomach acid production,
you're going to have a decrease in intrinsic factor secretion. So you're going to have low B12.
There's also genetic factors. If you have defects on your MTR gene and your MTRR gene, you're going
to be more prone to having issues in absorbing B12 too. B12 in the immediate is quite common.
And most people don't have an issue taking B12. The only thing that I would caution you about if
you take B12 is to take a subling will lossage would be better. It's better to get some absorption
in your mouth if it's an intrinsic factor issue. So if you take a lossage, B12 that you suck on
and you let it absorb in your mouth, you're going to get some absorption through your buccosa.
And that will kind of bypass the issue that you may be having with intrinsic factor.
And other absorption issues. So take it that way. Second caution is,
most of the B12 in the market is methyl cobalamine. And if you, you know, I know that's the big hype
that you should be taking methyl cobalamine and methyl tetrahedral folate because if you have
MTHFR defects, everybody should be on that. Probably that's just not true. You've got to look at the
whole picture. If a person has MTHFR defects or MTR and MTRR defects, still you don't necessarily want
to supplement with methyl groups, either methyl folate or methyl cobalamine. You want to look at the
other genetic pathways, your biopterate pathway, your serotonin production pathways.
And if you use methyl cobalamine or methyl folate into high concentration, it can push that pathway
and you could end up with excess serotonin levels. And in balance and serotonin levels could cause
age or rage issues and all sorts of different problems. So I would suggest to be safe, a hydroxyl
cobalamine or an adenosyl cobalamine. Stay away from the cyan cobalamine. So hydroxyl cobalamine or
adenosyl cobalamine in a lossage. That would be the best way to support that.
Always, though, when you have an abnormal blood test, always, always, always, you want to find out
why. You want to ask why. You know, you don't just use supplements like a medical doctor who would
use medicine without asking that question, why? You know, go back to, okay, if I do have low B12,
you know, what else is going on? Did you get an adequate, you know, complete CDC and metabolic
panel and other things too, to see if there's other things going on? There's patterns for hydrochlorohydria
that I mentioned as one of the causes of low B12. I have a video on that too. So go to the blog and search
HCL to search that and you'll see a video that I created a hypo, I created several blog posts
of low HCL production of your stomach. So look at that as well to make sure that you're doing
proper investigation instead of just putting a bad date on something.
Find a functional doctor that could help you with that if you need more help too.